foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello and good evening welcome to a Sky
News special program on the coronation
where you can have your safe ahead of
this weekend's celebrations over the
next hour we'll bring you the results of
exclusive polling from around the
country on the popularity of the
monarchy and we'll be taking your call
so get in touch let us know what you
think and whether Charles is a king
football
now as King Charles and queen Camilla
prepare to be crowned exclusive polling
for Sky News shows overall support for
the monarchy as drops
we'll look at the most popular members
of the war family and who they are among
the British public eight months on from
the death of Queen Elizabeth
and as the cost of living crisis
continues We'll be asking if the royal
family receive too much of our money
and we want you to have your say on the
coronation over the next hour by calling
0208 167 double two double zero that is
0208 167 double two double zero call us
now
[Music]
I am pleased to say that for the next
hour we'll be joined by the former Royal
correspondents now Royal commentator
Jenny Bond the author of the book and
what do you do what the royal family
don't want you to know Norman Baker and
the journalist and Royal commentator
afia Hagan now just before we get to
your calls let's take a look at some of
that polling that's been done for Sky
News in conjunction with ipsos
now we asked just over a thousand people
1004 to be precise should Britain become
a republic or remain a monarchy now the
Top Line there shows support for a
monarchy or the bottom line shows
support for a republic but it's the
yellow line in the middle that I want to
draw your attention to it shows net
support for the monarchy the most recent
polling showed a sharp dipping support
to plus 40 percent
and attitudes towards the royal family
differ depending on your age older
people age 55 to 75 have more positive
views of the Royals than Generation X or
Millennials in fact 28 of 18 to 34 year
olds had unfavorable views of the royal
family that's more than double of those
in the older category
now we want you to have yourself you can
call us on 0208 167 double two double
zeros let's get on with the calls and I
am pleased to say Paula from Sunderland
is on the line Paula what do you want to
say about the monarchy
I think basically the molecules are all
really really really important I I don't
think um I'm one of the older generation
obviously uh but I don't think that
people realize in the younger generation
what they actually do they have to
realize that um King Charles before he
got anywhere near becoming King he set
up the prince's trust and that is for
younger people and that has really
really really
improved people's understanding of
what's going on and improve their
confidence and their social skills so I
think the monarchy are still very very
good value
thank you for that Paul I do appreciate
you calling in let's just while we're on
the phone lines go to Kate's in
Manchester Kate you are on the air
hi there
um obviously not I do support the
printer's trust I think that will be his
legacy and a positive one at that
um I think there's been an air of
mystery about the royal family for some
years what that mystery is has gone now
I think uh Charles Camilla and William
and Kate have now taken that mystery
away due to the very social media
platforms and I think it's resorted to
them becoming more celebrities I think
what you see with Charles he's comes
across as meaningful but weak and then
it's evident that Camilla provides child
with a backbone Charles I think just had
young Camilla and in that way she
because then I accountability for
leaking to the Press I mean there's so
much I want to talk to you about I mean
I'd like to go into some detail about
William as well and the extent to what
he can offer and how he can change and
become more relatable to the younger
generation which I don't think he can at
the moment
um but you don't need to do it all in
one go we can come back to you so just
hang on there for a moment I want to
bring in our panel for a moment just to
kind of uh test the water and see where
we are with this so far I mean Jenny it
was quite clear wasn't there from the
first call that we had from Paula that
um she saw the positives of the monarchy
and especially the princess trust yeah
and you can't take that away from
Charles the princess trust is quite
extraordinary and has helped so many
people
um I think frankly you can do anything
you like with these pole findings you
can do anything you want with Statistics
because I can tell you from a poll taken
in 2000 that 40 of the younger
generation actually were angry about the
monarchy and so you could argue from
your poll that actually more young
people in favor now you can twist it
anywhere you want but the constant is
that there is Broad support in this
country for continuing a monarchy
um that's always every poll has shown a
majority for that yeah and Broad support
for the tuna monarchy Norman but perhaps
uh some of the people within the Mauna
Kea are losing support well I mean I
think the difference between the
position 12 months ago in the position
now is of course we no longer have the
queen and there was a high level of
support for the queen personally and I
think the royal family makes a mistake
to assume that the support for the queen
is the same as support for the monarchy
it isn't and I think part of the dips is
you've identified in your poll relates
to to that change after all we've seen
not my king placards demonstrations we
never saw us what I know and Jenny might
correct me not my queen placard we've
seen eggs throwing at um Charles I don't
think I ever remember an egg being
strong as a queen have been thrown at
the queen okay well have been protesters
on practically every tour I've been oh
they're not visible now certainly I
think maybe we're just covering them
more I think well I don't know who's
been out there have been eggs thrown at
him from what I can sort of tell very
very it's been more frequent than I I
remember more eggs I think we can agree
on more
more eggs so I think there is an issue
then about about
um the the way the monarchy presents
itself now because the queen was a
figure that nobody wanted to
particularly attack because people
thought she'd done quite a good job she
was an old lady and just a matter of
courtesy as much of anything else that's
now changed I think people are now
saying well hang on where are we going
and is this coronation which isn't a
sort of Imperial coronation appropriate
for the 21st century after let's bear in
mind that we got about nine European
monarchies only Britain has a
correlation nobody else had a
correlation the Spanish correlations
ended in 1555. we do like pageant for
you here don't we I feel I mean Norman's
kind of pushing it forward a little bit
there and and Kate in her in her answer
was also talking about the the change in
generation is really key here isn't it I
think social media it has a lot to play
in it in so far as we see a lot more of
what the rules are up to and we're able
to give our opinions on the rules a lot
more and that's a really good point that
Kate has made that she feels that the
Mystique of the royal family has been
lost because you know they've lifted the
carton behind what they get up to we see
them on social media and of course we
had Prince Harry's Memoir which told us
a lot about the royal family that we did
or did not want to know but she was also
I think making a really good point about
Prince William and appealing to younger
people and in fact William and Kate are
not the couple to do that because
they're in their 40s they're not exactly
the younger generation you know
um and that that that is what it is is
that what we need if the if the royal
family are going to appeal to the
younger generation to that 18 to 24
bracket then they need to have young
glamorous Royals to do that but also
King Charles needs to surround himself
with younger advisors with younger
people in office who can advise them how
best to appeal that younger to that
young a generation because without being
rude and with all due respects the
people that loved Queen Elizabeth II and
like King Charles III are not going to
be around forever it's horrible to say
but it's absolutely true so if we want
younger people to support the monarchy
then we need to appeal to them it has to
be done and who's going to do that it's
not Kate William and it's certainly not
Harry Megan well let's let's see what
Kate has to say about that Manchester in
Manchester okay I did interrupt you as
you're about to tell us about your
opinions on William I mean how much of
what Affair just said do you agree with
that the royal family need to start
appealing to a younger demographic and
it's perhaps with two people that have
been uh cast out somewhat
yes absolutely I mean uh to be fair to
Harry and Megan they did appeal to the
younger the younger generation they they
excelled at the overseas tours and
that's where the problem started with
them they become very extremely popular
and I think Kate and William had a
problem with that and I think they can
go back to you know 2020 and what I've
put on clear now about Williams
um deal with Murdoch and the settlement
Etc and perhaps the protection around
his family and that of you know the
media and scrutiny I think that needs to
be discussed as well but all this about
William doesn't bode well it comes
across you know as someone I would say
perhaps a bit you know angry you know
almost bullish and songs which is best
but I read I read a lot I've read a lot
of books and I do go on social media I'm
getting that from social media but
that's not what comes over on the media
and it's not what's written about in in
the tabloids thank you for that Kate
just quick thought from from you guys on
that I mean I mean Jenny Kate's making
it really clear there and making the
point for us here that social media has
allowed people to sort of form these
opinions and then spread the opinions
around amongst their sort of peer groups
and perhaps get a a different
understanding of of these people well I
mean social media is vicious there's no
way of getting around it
um if anyone like myself says uh
anything even mildly critical of her in
particularly Megan
um I get real abuse racial abuse as well
so it uh you know it has some benefits
but it is quite evil um I think William
probably is a very angry man I think he
has some reason to be angry and as we're
settling out of court with no the
Murdoch Empire well that's what um most
um settlements are in in hacking case I
mean a thousand
um cases been brought in nearly all have
been settled out of court and relatively
anonymously so it's not exceptional okay
what might be exceptional is the deal if
it's true that they would hold off any
settlement until such time as all the
other settlements had been agreed it
does seem to be in a special arrangement
for for William and Kate if what we've
said in the papers is true and of course
if that is true we'll find out in due
course of course because those cases are
going to be yeah all right guys for now
let's go back to the phones and Connie
in South West London Connie what do you
want to say
oh good evening
um the monarchist the monarchy for me is
completely relevant I have looked
forward to this coronation for many many
years I'm 68 years old now and grew up
to respect our Lake Queen and I'm just
so happy that Charles is now going to be
crowned he's waited a long time he's had
a long and extensive apprenticeship for
this and the way I look at it is it's a
date with Destiny he was born to be king
and it's his right to be king
I feel that as Prince of Wales he used
his money's work that he was given when
he left the Navy in 1976 and he set up
the princess trust that we all know
about and he has helped so many young
people at home and abroad with this very
active with all of that as well and I
think that with Queen Camilla Now by his
side he'll prove to be an excellent King
she she is somehow in my opinion sort of
softened him a bit as a person and I
think he feels very relaxed and happy
with her maybe it's also the fact that
he's now got grandchildren himself as
well and as for Camilla I think she is
more than worthy of her crown she has
been involved in lots of Charities very
close to her heart osteoporosis and of
course with the charity um for the women
that are caught up in domestic violence
so on Saturday I will swear my
allegiance to the king I will be proud
to do so and although protesters and
their placards please stay away we don't
need you spoiling our day we're going to
have a fantastic day and long live the
king and his Queen Camilla God bless
them both Connie thank you very much for
your call let's go to Chris in
Middlesbrough now Chris you are on the
air what do you want to say good good
evening and I think that King Charles
has proved over time that he's been more
right more often than the critics he's
picked up from from time to time I mean
in his environmentalism in his
architectural comments I think his time
has proven going to be more right than
than the Metropolitan chattering critics
that have infested his career
thank you very much for that Chris all
right guys there's a place to unpick
there let's start off with with with you
Norman I mean Connie really made it sort
of clear it's a sense of respect and
pride that she is clinging to that she
that she wants to to have replicated on
Saturday and she thinks that we should
all get behind that idea well I mean I'm
glad that she feels the way she does and
she feels very strongly and I hope she
has a very good day uh but equally we
are in a free country we're a democratic
country and one of the elements that is
key to our democracy is the right to
lawful and peaceful protests so it's not
right to say people shouldn't turn up as
they want to turn up and wave banners I
mean that's a perfectly legitimate thing
to do and indeed I hope the police won't
interfere with that because he did you
know when we had Xi Jinping over here
the Chinese leader the police the
Metropolitan Police hassled out of the
way all the Tibetans and and uyghurs who
are quite peacefully protesting so I
hope the police will in fact allow
lawful protest while obviously
preventing anything which isn't improper
and and Jenny the Metropolitan Police
have said that they're going to have
sort of zero tolerance for any kind of
disruption I mean there were reports in
the papers about alarms being thrown at
the horses I don't we don't know what's
going to happen on Saturday yet but the
police are going to have um they say a
very firm hand yeah but they've also
said that they want to engage with the
protesters rather than move them on
obviously they you know I can quite see
that they must have the right to protest
the Republicans who wish to be there I
think it's a bit rude frankly uh to to
Reign on as a bit of a punishment on
Charles's party
um but they have a right to I think is a
little bit sad I mean but they as you
say they do have the right it's the
obvious platform on which they should do
it but I do hope they don't disrupt the
procession I mean there are horses and
soldiers and people whose lives could be
put at risk never mind they're all
family I mean one thing that Connie said
that was really interesting to me I feel
I want to come to you on this was that
she said it's Charles's Destiny and this
is you know the idea that he was he was
born to this I mean of course it's
hereditary monarchy but is that part of
the thing as to why some people may find
find it uncomfortable what's happening
on Saturday well yes because it's you
know this family that have been you know
daned by God to rule over us and where
does that come from and why them and why
should it be them and why not anybody
else and why do we need that in the
first place that's what a lot of people
are questioning and it seems to be
around the coronation that a lot more
discussion about that is happening and
happening in the open and you have
Republic who seem to have
um sort of gained prominences at the
word like we're seeing a lot more of
them
exactly than they ever have been you
know but I didn't really hear about them
during the Jubilee of course during the
Queen's uh passing you know out of
respect I think they kind of held back
but now we're hearing so much more about
them and I think you know people are
really thinking about who is the royal
family who was the monarchy what do they
mean to us and Jenny you were talking
about social media earlier on I think
there is a danger of them falling in
into that trap of you know the cult of
the celebrity but it seems to be sort of
a celebrity family that's dysfunctional
that we pay for and so a lot of people
are like no not having that
um and I guess that really Rings true
amongst the Young on younger generation
but other people as well and you know
they have had their issues through the
years that do play out now like a soap
opera will you come in normal I want to
get a quick thought from you on that
idea of the of the destiny the
hereditary nature of this Monica is that
where the generational thing comes in is
it sort of the generational thing
changes from generation to generate is a
constant and every time someone passes
that 18 to 24 age group and getting sort
of 35 I think oh oh you know it's all
right status quo so that's a constant
but isn't it more about the sort of the
ordained by God isn't it that more that
sort of religious element I think I mean
it's ludicrous the whole idea is
ludicrous of her energy monarchy of
course it is doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and I don't think they
particularly like it the royal family
either they talk about their their
destiny and Charles spoke about his sort
of grotesque Destiny he realized um
Diana talked to me about William feeling
that the burden of kingship even when he
was a young boy weighed heavily on his
shoulders it's a life of enormous
privilege of course but of enormous
restriction and constraint it's a life
their view of service
um and I haven't got a problem
whatsoever with with having a republic I
I love politics having another election
yeah let's go forever president I'd love
that but the fact of the matter is it it
appears to work just one last thought it
appears to work
um as a as a way of being in this
country and it I do think that if you
had a referendum tomorrow the majority
of those who voted would say yes let's
keep the monarchy
they would say yes that's perfectly true
and let me preface what I want to say
about saying actually I agree with
Charles on a whole range of issues to
pick up one of the earlier comments that
were made on environmental issues and so
on however the trouble with the
hereditary monarchy is this you get
who's next in line whether they're any
good or not and and you can get someone
who is I said you was a queen was
assiduous I think in her duties George V
was rather boring but did his job
properly Edward V8 was a Nazi
sympathizer we all knew he was on the
run-up to the second world war now the
trouble is that people take a note of
allegiance to the king including the
Armed Forces then that may be
uncontroversial with Charles and
uncontroversial with Elizabeth when she
was on the throne it wouldn't have been
uncontroversial with Edward VIII who
could have said had he still been on the
throne in 1939 lay down your arms
because that's what he wanted to happen
he wanted to deal with Nazi Germany so
we're very very careful with the
relative principle that we don't get the
wrong person who'd you get when we vote
May I mention the list trust
we've got rid of them but you see you
get rid of politicians
this is the thing is that we say that
you know it works or this hereditary
monarchy works it carries on does it
work because I mean the princess trust
is great that's amazing Duke of
Edinburgh award was also excellent but
what are they doing for us and what what
are they doing
if you can pick up on that I mean it
seems it's one of those things that
works until it just doesn't exactly
let's go to let's go to Steve in
Manchester and Steve you are on the air
former member of the Armed Forces what
do you uh want to tell our panel
elimination
I agree everybody yeah um I I say you
know I'm 42. uh I pledge north of
allegiance to mostly the queen and to
her and successes and that brings True
to this day and it always will it runs
thick in my bud as it will many many
members of the Armed Forces serving and
Veterans I also believe that the
monarchy is in very safe hands with King
Charles and queen Camilla and I think
the public nomination needs to get used
to the idea that she's going to be Queen
Camilla not Queen console and let's look
back into history and if I'm right I'm
sure the Queen's mum had the same title
and it was changed when she married the
Queen's father and again the monarchy a
lot of people forget it brings in so
much money
um to our nation notorious come far and
wide 12 countries to see your family to
visit the Palisades and bring in so much
money into this country through in
tourism-wise that they don't realize
this and I think the monarchy is in safe
hands for the future now and for the
future and I think
King Charles Queen people that are going
to do an absolutely fantastic job as
will the rest as he goes down all these
and successors so as I say God save our
King all right Steve really do
appreciate that I mean no one's sort of
making I am I mean there's two things uh
taking your notes to Charles I suppose
is one thing but taking it to his ears
and successes let's just remember that
in the top 10 of those who are on the
line of succession they include both
Harry and Prince Andrew neither of whom
I think people want to stick in those
religions to but that's what the youth
says heirs and successes and as far as
Camille is concerned I don't want to be
well we will come on to our next I'm
sure that is going to be a topic that
we're all going to want to discuss I do
want to go back to Colleen though in
South London he said she's gonna be
having
uh I'm being told in my ear that we
don't have even though I was sure we did
um let's uh carry on if we can now if
you'd like to post a message to the new
king and queen ahead of the coronation
you can do so what I need you to do is
get your phone out and scan that QR code
that you see on your screen right now
it's going to take you to our app where
you can leave a message let's take a
look at some of the message messages
that we've had so far now the ronans got
in touch and said we're all looking
forward to watching the coronation this
weekend they go on to say thank you for
your service to this amazing country
your parents will be looking down with
pride God say the king now Pammy wrote
I was six when I watched the Queen's
coronation now 76 uh a bit like a Connie
was saying and I'll be watching like
King being crowned I hope you serve our
country as well as your mum did hope
it's a great day for you and your family
and we had Alberto Techo who wrote not
sure what the royal family does but long
live the king appreciate everyone who is
getting in touch and he got a chocolate
from the panel which is always good all
right you are watching our special
coronation phoning program a king for
all you're safe coming up we'll look at
who the most popular members of the
royal family are stay with us for that
and don't forget you can get in touch
foreign
[Music]
hello there and welcome back to our
special program a king for all you'll
say before we get back to the phone
lines let's take a look at some more of
that polling that we've done in
conjunction with ipsos now Charles is
going to be officially crowned in just a
matter of days but how popular is he
well we asked
1079 adults at the beginning of April
and here's what they said 52 of people
said they feel favorably toward the
Monarch while 21 said the opposite now
if we do the math and take one away from
the other we see the King has a net
favorability of plus 31 so big jump from
2018 when he was at just plus three
so now we know that King Charles's
popularity has increased the King has a
net variability of plus 31 but how does
that compare to other members of the
family well there they are on your
screen now he is slightly ahead than the
royal family as a whole which has a net
favorability of plus 29. now in contrast
the queen console has a net favorability
of just plus eight out of all the rules
the Princess Royal is the most liked
alongside the prince and princess of
Wales they had net favorability ratings
of 47 but Harry and Megan are down the
other end along with prince Andrew who
has stepped down from a public duties
following a series of scandals he has
the lowest net favorability at minus 55
percent
all right let's go back to the phone
Zender so what you make of that polling
Bob in Cornwall you are on the air would
you make of the fact that uh Queen
Camilla has only got eight percent
favorability ratings
her by side is really
um
I think it should help his uh his
polling um he's been preparing to be
king his whole life
um his intelligent compassionate
sensitive to people's needs
a public opinion is is dedicated and I
honestly think that Queen Camilla
is
part of that a big part of that
okay so guys even though Camilla has
such low Prof administrations in our
polling it's the second time that that
word strength has been used when
describing Camilla in Charleston well I
think she does give him strength and I
think he'd be rather weaker without it
that's true but there's another opinion
Paul a couple of weeks ago which hasn't
received much coverage which is only 14
percent of people think that she should
be called Queen and others want to Queen
consort or in fact Duchess of cornball
to to remain if we go back generally
remember this better than I do but
originally she wasn't going to be called
Queen at all she could recall I think Dr
de Cornwell and then Queen consort is
that right print check concert that's
right and and then so the queen title is
a relatively recent addition and I just
think given the history of this with
Diana and indeed with some sympathy and
thought for the boys Harry and William
it would be better if she hadn't been
called Queen well Jen's worth explaining
exactly why she is going to be given the
title of Queen console well
um Queen if you marry a king you'll call
Queen that's the simplest that's the
simple answer
um as regards Queen consort or queen
well uh prince Queen Alexandra was Queen
consort Queen
um Mary was Queen consult we don't call
them that we call them Queen Mary we've
gone Queen Alexandra Queen Elizabeth the
queen mother so it's just it's a short
turn if you like so that's that's a
natural thing I go very cross when
people say that Camilla shouldn't be
Queen I think it's insulting to the
woman who hasn't made a mess of their
private lives for goodness sake can we
move on and stop wicking them and saying
you made a bad marriage you behave badly
these guys have loved each other for 50
years he is proud to have this woman as
his wife and he um he is King and she is
quite rightly going to be called Queen
that's my view I mean he is King and she
will be Queen but that doesn't mean that
the public are necessarily happy me
anecdotally from some people I have
spoken to there seems to be a lot of uh
upset about the idea of Queen Camilla
yeah and I've heard a lot of the same
and I think there is a real hangover
from
um that past relations ship from Charles
and Diana now if if we had been sitting
here in 1997 the polling would have been
in single digits for a King Charles for
popularity and it for us talking about
you know King Charles to marry Camilla
and for her to be crowned alongside him
and be Queen it was never going to
happen it was like a pint and I was
sitting here exactly but there was no
chance of it was there no problem no
chance and you're you're absolutely
right what you say what a journey and
isn't that brilliant that we've moved on
as a nation from the days of Wallace
Simpson and Edward VII when he couldn't
marry the woman he wanted because she
was divorced because he was American
when when Charles couldn't marry Camilla
because she had form and we've moved on
and as I say so many people are in
second third marriages this is a new
blended family which mirrors the Blended
families and extended families and
screwed up families that that is the
nation absolutely I mean I I could I
could not agree with you more that I'm
glad that we've moved on to a time where
someone can have a second marriage and
can have a blended family that
definitely reflects modern Britain
however you have to remember that the
British people hold up the royal family
to a completely different standards then
they hold themselves or their own family
so we want our royal family our family
that are the dained from God Head of
State to be pure than pure whiter than
white no second marriages no Blended
families no Memoirs no one of color we
don't want any of that we want that pure
blood family and that's what that's why
a lot of British people still have this
hangover from that time of Diane and
Charles so therefore don't want Camilla
to be Queen wanted to be Queen console
or queen Camilla I mean Bob um you're
still with us I think just what do you
think of that idea that you know that
it's a great sign that we have moved on
as a country or do you still feel that
there is a little animosity about the
fact that the families seems so
dysfunctional it doesn't set such a
great example does it
um yeah
oval
um don't go wrong I I love Diana she was
obviously a heroine to us
um but it just wasn't meant to be
um if he'd had the chance to actually
marry Camilla to begin with we wouldn't
be having this
um debate as such
so to me she's
she needs to be given that chance
okay Bob do appreciate that Norman quick
thought from you I'm very happy if
they're happy together and I'm very
nothing against him marrying her I just
don't think she should call Queen why
but because because Diana was the one
who should be called Queen and Dan is no
longer there I'm happy
to becoming concert
I personally wouldn't no and I think
that's in line actually with the
majority of people in the country that
opinion Paul I called you only 14 thinks
she should be Queen oh it's like saying
you know if you're going in a second
marriage you can't be called Mrs no it's
different when you're a head of States
it's not quite the same Journey well I
think it's mean
all right I thought it was gonna be more
there but that was putting that was
plenty normally thank you so much for
that let's go back to the phones Michael
in Bolton you are on the air I mean what
do you think do you think that we should
have a queen Camilla
to be honest all this kind of argument
about should you be Queen shouldn't she
be Queen it's an issue of semantics like
it's
she's with King Charles that's lovely
fine
she should be queen or not it all feels
like it's just some sort of Gossip
magazine or some sort of glorified soap
you know family like I live in Greater
Manchester they're all family like I'm
going to be trying to avoid the
combination because I had a bad enough
time when the Queen's funeral was on you
know but they're lovely people the royal
family but at the same time really have
much relevance to my everyday life and a
lot of people particularly my generation
I'm a millennial and the younger
generation
don't have that connection and like
I've I've seen the queen when I was you
know very young she came to Morecambe
where I'm from and but at the same time
it's kind of the fact that we we spend
hours and hours saying oh should she be
Queen shouldn't she be Queen what
particular label are we going to put on
her and this kind of obsession
is just feels a bit silly because it's
kind of
almost suspended ourselves
and kind of suspended our disbelief of
kind of all the real life and just gone
oh let's play let's let's play royalty
for a little bit it feels a bit silly
like whatever they decide they decide
what it's kind of whether she's queen or
not really care so Michael then more
broadly I mean what do you what do you
think about the monarchy would you want
to see it continuing on in its in its
current former do you want to see it
change you want to see it done away with
entirely
I think it's your change if we're going
to keep it you know
talk about the tourism and that seems to
be the key thing that royalists seem to
put forward you know I mean I'll be
honest I've not really seen many
tourists I know come to specifically
meet King Charles or Prince William go
and see
um Buckingham Palace which is where
there's a royalty there or not that's
still they're not going to knock it down
if we get rid of the royalty
we should have like at back like you
know not many people are going to know
about the royal family of Norway but to
have a much lesser role within Norwegian
society and
you know they're just kind of
figureheads like the prince you know
sort of like the King was when he was a
prince he was just kind of a figurehead
and supported charities
it's fine there wasn't all this drama
and obsession over oh who's going to get
this is Harry going to come to the
combination I think I'm going to keep
the if you're going to keep the royal
family which of other countries are
thinking of getting rid of them you know
Jamaica good luck to them and because
perfectly good reason to do so
keep it just be figureheads we shouldn't
have this weird Obsession and kind of
give them as much power as they have
because
a lot for charity
great
21st century Britain
feels like we're trying to relive great
you know rural Britannia and all the
kind of stuff that we saw with brexit
and the kind of culture wars and
everything like that and it's it's
trying to back to a time that's
anything since gone
okay appreciate that opinion uh Michael
thank you very much for that let's go to
another call Anthony you're in Exeter
what do you want to say
hello good evening thank you for having
me on what a cracking debate
um
I was nine years old I was nine years
old when uh
Godzilla the the late queen Queen
Elizabeth II
um had her coronation
um what a paragon of respectability and
protocol she was never explain never
never complain
um I had trouble associating that
definition with Charles and Camilla I'm
afraid and I take issue with um the
Monarchy Living off the taxpayer The
Sovereign grant that the monarchy
receives is uh phenomenal so Charles
himself
um paid no inheritance tax after his
mother died his land Fortune is
eye-watering the duchy have called
itself rake in a fortune
um it's worth 1.5 billion he owns
two-thirds of Dartmoor and the taxpayer
pays for his accommodation transport
their accommodation transport chicks
helicopters
um his security alone for this Kabuki
pantomime in Westminster Abbey on
Saturday is 150 million
um
our only salvation I think is for uh
maybe William will give a nod for a
country that will have an elected State
an elected head of state and not be
asked to swear allegiance to someone the
taxpayer keeps
um now wouldn't that be a vision
it may well be Anthony do appreciate you
uh adding to the debate right guys let's
pick up some of that stuff there and I
don't actually know quite where to start
but let's start with the idea of a
kabuki pantomime this this weekend I
mean seven thousand armed forced person
it's a big old panto though
um yes I think um and eleven thousand
police sir at least uh yes it is very
expensive I'm in two minds about whether
we should be having this coronation I
think perhaps it will be the last
coronation we'll see as you quite
rightly say normal it doesn't happen in
Europe
um people are going to enjoy the Pomp
and pageantry if you're into that and it
is a heck of a spectacle it really is uh
but in this cost of living crisis should
it be happening would it be much better
for that money to be diverted to uh
perhaps
um reparation for slavery
um something like that uh I kind of feel
feel that that would have been a bigger
gesture well that would have been a
gesture and there was talk about being
it being a slimmed down coronation but
it does thousand people
as it could be I mean Jenny you
obviously been a royal commentator for
for some time
some experience and you know what you're
talking about what is it why did Prince
Charles want now King Charles want this
to be such a such a show when there were
options for him to not have it I think
there's I haven't actually asked him but
I think there are a number of reasons um
one is that he feels that he's a very
spiritual man and this is a religious
service at the heart of it is religion
um and I feel he wants that that
sanctity and that sacredness of it
another thought that has occurred to me
is that you know this this is going to
be his big moment and he's not going to
get another one he's um he's 74 going on
75. we're not going to see a silver
jubilee being realistic so uh this is
his big chance for that but I think
honestly at the heart of it um it's his
feeling that this is a very serious job
and he wants it all to be about service
not
a religious service but devotion
devoting himself to a life of service
and he feels he needs this big
coronation to do that because of course
there's the sort of the Sacred moments
when he's Anointed with oil I mean
Anthony you're still with us I believe
um
what do you make of the size of what
we're about to see I mean you called it
a a kabuki pantom I mean I guess you
wanted it to be slimmed down entirely
this idea that you know this is Prince
Charles's King Charles's chance to have
this big moment and it says Destiny is
one of our previous callers described it
well I've I've lived through his
his uh we're the same age or one
slightly older than hey I've lived
through his life and observed him and
his uh his marriage to Diana and uh the
association with Camilla and everything
um when she to be fair I mean perhaps
Camilla went through a hell of a time uh
after they they got together and she was
trying to to uh uh associate with the
monarchy and and she she was she was
vilified in so many ways
um I I I I just had trouble with Charles
King Charles I just had trouble with her
with him being King it's because of an
old fart 79 years of age you know I had
a queen for so long
um that we respected and love uh now
we've got a a young couple Kate and
William who were coming through and I
watched the the the lovely trip through
Soho today with a stopping off at the
pub they had time to to travel on the
tube oh my God wasn't that phenomenal
um it's uh that their TR must be
fabulous
I I I just can't get my head around
Charles and Camilla as Queen I can't do
it it's a anathema to me
Anthony really appreciate you you're
calling in and taking part in this
discussion I just want to go to another
call we've got Peck in Colchester uh
Peck what did you want to say
uh yeah I wanted to say that actually
there is significance in um the royal
family and the Monaco in the whole I
mean Britain is that is a simple
symbolism of Britain isn't it because
it's what really many people around the
world they look and admire like the UK
as as a whole
like the royal family and even me as a
citizen of a republic country I'm from
Singapore actually
um I don't know sure that is
free of importance
than considering the traditions
myself
okay Peck do appreciate that we uh
thank you all for for calling you guys
we're going to go to a break now so uh
stay with us you're watching our special
coronation program a king for all have
your say now coming up do the rules
deserve do the rules receive sorry your
hand to serve as much of our money as
they get
[Music]
I couldn't hear Peck at all then
unfortunately
well welcome back to our special program
a king for all your Saint let's take a
look at the issue of money now the royal
family is funded Through The Sovereign
Grant which was just over 100 million
pounds last year slightly higher than
usual due to Palace Renovations so does
the Royal Family received too much money
we asked our 1008 respondents in our
poll with ipsos and it shows the number
of people
who are happy with the mind of the royal
family receives has fallen in recent
years and have a look at how public
opinion changed in context of different
events happening in Britain at the time
1992 was the Queen's Annis horribles the
year in which two of her children
separated from their Partners details of
Princess Diana's private life were
published as well as there being a fire
at Windsor Castle
2012 however there was an uptick in
support and that is the year of course
of the London Olympic games all right
guys so look
it as Jenny said it does go up and down
in terms of how people feel about 2012
is it was the Olympic Games but it was
the Jubilee it was the Diamond Jubilee
much more relevant much exactly and she
jumped out the plane with James Bond
which was excellent helicopter
um as you rightly pointed out the
polling does go up and down on this but
you know looking at The Sovereign ground
I think it's about one pound 29 per
person well the palace say it costs one
pound 29 but I don't know if I'd
actually believe that right The
Sovereign
civil list for 7.9 million in 2011 and
The Sovereign last year I think around
saying was 86.3 Million not 100 million
that's a massive increase in in that 10
or year period and it's not just that
you look at the uh tax breaks which is
what the family uniquely gets the fact
that there's no death duties paid on the
private partition not to talk about the
crown jewels and things the private
possessions which are passed from the
Queen the fabergy eggs the spring of
race horses the paintings you know why
should Charles be exempt from paying
debtors but no one else in the country
is what about the land as well and
there's all the land there's a duchy of
Cornwall and duchy of Lancaster which uh
if I may say so kind of Royal slush
funds that's what I'm concerned uh the
duchy of Cornwall was regarded until
East 1921 as a government Department
belonging to the state and it shouldn't
be money going towards the print of
Wales whoever he is at the time it
should go in straight into the treasury
I mean because yes and a lot of the the
ducky of land Catholic of Cornwall duchy
of Lancaster and Dartmoor that's
disputed Lance you know so they
shouldn't be making 1.5 billion pounds
of that and they shouldn't be examined
from tax and yes you know maybe they
only cost us one pound 29 is often Grand
but they're getting so many tax breaks
they're costing us way more money and
this is the thing is that when we are in
this cost of living crisis when people
have had a pretty hard winter where
they've had to choose between Heating
and eating and we see all those
headlines but that is a reality for a
lot of people all this pump and
pageantry golden carriages orbs sectors
Imperial crowns St Mary's Crown your
crime micro and Jenny's Crown it's
rubbing salt in the wound for people and
that is absolutely not what they want to
see at all it's all right for King
Charles III to you know do a Christmas
speech where he says you know he
acknowledges that people are going
through a hard time and it talks about
people who've worked hard during the
pandemic and invites them all to the
coronation you've made 1.5 billion
pounds off your land how about you
spread that amongst the people you deign
to Reign Over okay thank you Jenny
you're going to come back in in a moment
I want to go to another call we've got
Bob in Berkshire Bob we don't have loads
of time left what do you want to say
well um actually I've been a lifelong
royalist I served in the ministry of
Defense I was at the treasury actually
when Prince Charles was a thing for the
shelves came to the treasury to come to
the public um the policy Coordination
Committee back in 1982 I think it was
and um and throughout my life I've
respected them as an institution I think
they represent something which is a bit
more
um a bit different to what most people
talk about when they talk on the media
they um represent a different status in
terms of the way in which the
Constitution is formed they keep us safe
from having sort of complete fools and
becoming presidents Etc and um and I
think that sort of you know listening to
the debate this then
um yeah we just spent 400 billion pounds
telling people stay at home so that
during covert who spent another 100
billion pounds on quantitative easing so
we spent 500 billion pounds in total on
getting absolutely zero for the UK
economy and here we have a royal family
who for a very small should allow money
so they don't give us Great Value and
for me you know I they have my I'm dying
legal scheme and my own dying love
appreciate that John let's go to
Inverness uh where John is standing by
John
hello good evening
hello hi John in Inverness can you hear
me yes I can hear you you're on the air
go ahead John what did you want to say
tell me what I want to see us and I
don't I don't think any um King Charles
and Camilla I mean and to be on the
throne and and the reasons for that is
um
are very much loved person in the UK and
the other countries he was loved by all
the people and that happened to Diane it
really upset me and a lot of others and
Camilla with and then and if she was
just seeing as King Charles and she knew
it was wrong what they were doing and
they and they actually got to
um you know I mean The Sovereign Grant
and the 2021 to 22 and was set at 86.3
million that is roughly
1.29 points for every person in the UK
payments and they extend from an
agreement to Rochester made with a
British government and in 1760 to give
up income from the monasteries
properties in exchange for a fixed
annual payment it went up to cover the
Queen's funeral or
or the coordination
every family and in the UK and Northern
Ireland and they and Wales and we
you know say you know excuse me tax
deals movies are coming to cover this
call as coordination there's 11 and a
half thousand policemen and we will be
at the coronation and not that
experience extincts
it's been full of Scandal over there the
past few years and they print so I'm
good for one I mean it's been hard
there's one more caller we only got
about a couple of minutes left so I do
thank you for calling in I just want to
go to null in Sussex and no we don't
have loads of time so if you can make
your point put a piece of things please
I I will indeed Kamal hello I think
thank you for having me I I think I
think the panel leads to to focus really
on the good that's going to come out of
this weekend I mean the whole country's
in the bars everyone's Street parties
bunting everywhere I think everyone's so
looking forward and so excited and I
think the panel should focus on all of
the good that's going to come out of it
it's not like the king charges but he
shouldn't be held responsible for the
sort of behavior of other members of his
family uh he's a good King and I think
she's going to make a great Queen I
think we should just the whole balance
should celebrate that and I'm all for us
and lots of people I know are all for it
and long live the king and queen right
thank you very much for that no I've
only got a couple of minutes left of
fear but I I hear what Noel is saying
but Noel also has to realize that
there's a lot of people who don't have
the bunting out are not interested don't
care about it and there's a lot of
people who are Furious that this is
happening and this amount of money has
been spent and they can't focus on the
good it was something I said earlier as
well by Michael that talked about sort
of dragging back this Rule Britannia
culture as well Jenny which I think is
is a danger that many people see when
you're sort of seeing all these Pomp and
Circumstance on the streets well you
don't have to take part you don't have
to watch it go to the beach do something
else and you you have a choice a lot of
people are going to enjoy it and I would
just say um about Camilla
um that I sat with Diana in her drawing
room and talked about Camila and Camilla
in Diana's view had been loyal discreet
and deserve some form of recognition
where she's going to get it on Saturday
well just on I hope people do enjoy it
if they're interested in these matters
I'd like people to enjoy whatever
they're doing at the weekend
um but the fact is there's only a wet
blanket but there are far fewer Street
parties taking place this weekend than
took place to Queens Jubilee that's a
that's a fact statistical fact on the
correlation Charles wanted to slim down
coronation this one's costing 250
million pounds even if you take away the
security which is 150 million 100
million that's twice as much in real
terms as what the Queen Elizabeth had in
1953 how is that him down is twice as
expensive as it was and the other thing
is just to pick up on on the Palaces
that has been been referred to earlier
on the palace with the most visitors in
Europe is the Palace of Versailles and
the French go to demonic in 1848. so you
know the Bush whatever you think about
the monarchy there was ludicrous
argument in favor of the monarchy is it
good for tourism that's a really bad
argument and I think they bring in some
estimated to be 19 billion pounds in
well that's people drinking in the pups
you think there's lots of ways to bring
money all right guys that has been a
really excellent discussion we
appreciate it very much thank you very
much for coming in at Jenny Norman
Affair uh I know what you're gonna be
doing at the weekend you're going to be
watching the coronation though fear I'm
going to be talking about it on TV
General we're doing the same thing
we're all broadcasting yeah well do we
appreciate you guys coming and enjoy the
week and whatever you get up to that is
all from the phone and coming up is
Jamaica about to remove the king as its
head of state and become a
there's plenty more to come on Sky News
after this short break
[Music]
don't save the king
over us